the queue trailed out of the hospital
gates and down the street the stark
warning of an imminent tidal wave of
omicron prompting a massive surge of
vaccine uptake at hundreds of
vaccination centers across the uk
the prime minister visited a vaccination
center to see the work firsthand and
broke the news of the uk's first omicron
related death omicron is producing
hospitalizations and
sadly at least one patient has now
been confirmed to have died
with omicron so
i think the idea that this is somehow a
milder version of the virus i think
that's something we need to set on one
side and just recognize the sheer
pace at which it accelerates through the
population the mission to offer millions
of booster jabs by december 31st will
see 42 military planning teams deployed
across every health region extra vaccine
sites and mobile units extended clinic
opening hours to allow people to be
jabbed around the clock and at weekends
and the training of thousands more
volunteer vaccinators
hitting the government's target would
mean one million jabs being put into
people's arms every single day between
now and the end of december and that's
never been achieved before currently the
nhs is managing around half of that but
the importance of trying has been
emphasized by new modelling which shows
that in some circumstances omicron could
cause double the number of
hospitalizations that delta did a year
ago
and the booster jab gives 70 protection
against infection
new rules on wearing masks and working
from home have now also come into effect
in england passenger numbers on public
transport have dropped significantly and
many businesses are cancelling their
end-of-year parties but there are
determined pockets of political and
public resistance to new restrictions
i've been speaking to a lot of people i
don't think that the compliance will be
as high as it has been in past lockdowns
simply because
we've had this stint of
basically no restrictions
with the christmas holiday less than two
weeks away it's going to be a race
against time to avoid even more
stringent restrictions paul brennan al
jazeera london